S Gaurav Dad Congratulations I Give You Two
Options One You Either Take Yo 000
Today And Exactly A Year Later Which One Would
Gaurav Prefer Gaurav Says Of Course Today
Dad Gaurav Does Not Want To Wait For Another Year Why Did
Gaurav Want The Money Today And Not  A
year later even do it's the same amount It's
simple He thinks he can spend the money this
year He can buy a football and nice shoes and a
play station game with that money and enjoy himself this year And who knows his dad might even
change his  Mind a Year Later So Why
Wait for Another Year This Is All You Need to Know to Understand What
Interest is 000 Today
is Not 000 A Year
Later Let Us Consider Another Example Consider
a Bank A bank is an institution which nominally allows us
to make deposits.  And Also Gives Us
Loan And This Is Edward Awesome He
Deposits ₹1 In The Bank Today So One Year
Later The Bank Gives Him 08 Wait Why Did The Bank
Pay Edward More Than How Much He Had Deposited It Is Simple
The Bank Gets To Use The  ₹1 For That One Year
So To Reward Edward The Bank Page Him
More Than How Much He Had Deposited Now Your
Concept Is Clear Now We Just Need To Understand
Some
Terminology This ₹ Bees Is Called The
Principle It Is Basically The Initial Amount
And What Edward  What Edward gets after a year is
composed of two parts One part is that he
gets back his principal of ₹1 and
the 8 that is left with him is called the
interest and what Edward gets after a year
is ₹1 of principal and 8 of
interest so  The bank is paying interest to
Edward for aligning it to keep his ₹1 for a
year and the sum of these two is called as the amount. The amount always equals
the sum of the
principal and the
interest since Edward got 8 on his
investment of
₹.  Rate Off [Music] Interest On 1 V That He Got N 8